as a headline act and the adventure is
for sure this is my first year as
executive chair the Edinburgh Festival
is officially the world's largest
cultural event and we're very very
closely linked to it and have been for
40 years
the very first TV festival was
effectively tagged on as an informal
creative gathering to discuss the
cultural issues of the time facing our
industry and by all accounts it was a
relaxed free thinking free drinking
experience and there wasn't a press
officer a spin doctor in sight let alone
a culture secretary I think that idea of
a relaxed creative gathering still holds
true for us though obviously commerce
technology globalization and politics
play their part to this festival like
every other festival still aims to be
fun sociable and provocative and for
those of you who saw the Big Brother
session this morning I think we've
ticked most of those boxes already but
this festival also has a more serious
charitable purpose unlike most of our
rival events we're not a commercial
business all our profits go towards our
two fantastic training schemes the ones
to watch and the network and this year's
trainees are out in force tonight yes
that rowdy bunch are going to be your
bosses one day so be nice to them the
festival is managed brilliantly by art
director Lisa Campbell and her full-time
team but in truth it doesn't happen
without the full support of you the
delegates and all our sponsors and all
the busy TV folk who participate and
produce the sessions and make it happen
thank you all very much first and
foremost of those volunteers is our
festival curator this year's advisory
chairs I Bennett so please put your
hands together and welcome sign onto the
stage
thanks Chris thank you I felt very lucky
when Chris asked me to be this year's
advisory chair it's a huge
responsibility curating what is a
cornerstone of our industry and
particularly in this is 40th anniversary
year when I sat down with Lisa Campbell
the festival director we decided we
wanted to achieve three main things with
the program this year we wanted to put
talent at the heart of the festival we
wanted to make it feel truly
international and we wanted to make sure
it is as agenda setting and entertaining
as possible you will be the judges of
whether or not we've achieved any of
those but given that so far today we
have set K Burley loose on the leaders
of the Maine broadcasters heard that
John Whittingdale thinks that w1a has a
ring of truth about it and electrocuted
a set of middle-aged TV executives
dressed in lycra bodysuits I think we're
doing pretty well glancing across the
program for the next two days I'm
tremendously looking forward to getting
the view from the across the Atlantic
from show times David Nevins effects his
John Landgraf and Amazon's Roy price
listening to Martin Friedman in
conversation with Mark Lawson and seeing
Ron Perlman in the hand of God while
Frankie Boyle hosting this year's
Edinburgh Awards makes that ceremony an
absolute must see I have to thank the
exceptional Advisory Committee who have
pulled this year's program together my
tireless deputy Kate Phillips and the
festival team led by Lisa Campbell who
actually do all the work we should
remember that the producer the sessions
and the members of all the committees
have given up their time expertise and
energy for free to pull these sessions
together as of all the contributors the
presenters and professionals in them
this sacrifice is all to help power the
festival's amazing charity schemes which
Chris has already mentioned I also want
to thank my fantastic employee sky and
my generous boss Stuart Murphy for
supporting me and the festival so
fulsomely this year I promise I'll come
back to the office now so on to the main
event the choice of McTaggart lecture
sets the tone for the entire festival
when we first discussed who would like
to deliver this year's festival we were
clear Earl this is prestigious speech we
were clear that we wanted to create a
creative at the top of their game
someone who has done done it all and can
deliver a personal independent
dissection of our industry
Armando Iannucci is an Oscar and Emmy
nominated writer director and producer
his credits include the thick of it I am
Alan Partridge and veep throughout his
career
Amanda has worked with the BBC for both
radio and television as well as with Sky
HBO channel four and in feature films
he's a regular contributor to The
Observer The Telegraph and the Guardian
and is currently adapting a new version
of Charles Dickens David Copperfield for
the big screen as well as a feature film
about the death of Stalin as a
heavyweights of the TV industry and a
former resident of Hollywood Amanda now
comes with an entourage she's genuine
rider for tonight's lecture was pretty
incredible he asked for one or two
packets of salt and vinegar crisps a
couple of bananas and a bottle of water
Hollywood has changed him ladies and
gentlemen giving the 2015 James
McTaggart Memorial Lecture please
welcome Armando Iannucci
ah
thank you guys I thank you trainees
thank you everyone staring nervously out
at you all my future sitting in front of
me and a slightly Nuremburg Ian backdrop
behind me I actually call that red
Nuremberg 'ti my mind goes back 15 years
when I was lacet into a BBC
brainstorming session on the arts and I
spent the day in a brightly painted room
at the mercy of a team of professional
arts brainstorm 'as now these were
experts paid to be spontaneously
positive they had degrees in being
upbeat and had trained with some of the
world's most optimistic people this is a
day to let your hair down said the
leader it's all about having fun we want
to have fun and then she looked straight
at us
if you're not prepared to have fun get
out now
I got out and I resolved that the last
thing I would ever do is trap a group of
talented people in a colourful room and
subject them to one-sided opinion
masquerading as open debate until now
so if you're not prepared to hear why I
think politicians have got the British
television industry completely wrong
because they peer at it through a filter
of their own prejudices and that's a
fact
then get out now so those staying
can I start by saying what an honor it
is to be asked to give this James
McTaggart memorial lecture tonight and
in this its 40th year looking back to
1976 we can see how far the TV landscape
has changed then the big classics were
Thunderbirds David Attenborough and
Poldark
so let's congratulate ourselves on how
far we've come
we were told television would by now
have changed utterly we were told that
by people paid to know they said viewing
would decline and be replaced by mobile
and laptop alternatives and indeed brash
new entities such as Amazon and Netflix
have emerged bringing streaming digital
pictures are a telecommunicators
sequence of visual data or tell a vision
if you will which immerse us in dynamic
new forms of storytelling such as the
one-hour drama and provide us with
revolutionary news stories such as house
of cards now I suppose what this really
tells us is that there are eternal
verities even in television which time
will never change we may alter and
innovate how we watch from set to laptop
to tablet and yes unbelievably to a
watch but we still crave the same things
basically costumes and cakes
but
but wait the experts told us wait our
attention span will diminish and we'll
hop from three-minute clip to six-second
vine to nanosecond blap tiny-tiny
singularities of entertainment that
spell the death of long-form viewing
instead we binge watch four seasons
worth of quality box sets in one weekend
sitting through what is effectively a
48-hour television program well our
children grow hungry and cold so much
for experts there guess is as good as
yours but more expensive
they proclaimed the death of the book
but did so in best-selling books
economic experts failed to predict the
banking crisis but still cash their
checks earlier in May
Pauling experts said that would be a
hung parliament and now they carry on
like we still think they're credible or
maybe that's what they're polling is
telling them the truth is nobody knows
anything and that's because we're all
individually full of contradictions
we're all annoyingly deliciously
unknowable beyond algorithmic reach for
now in fact the recent general election
provides a perfect matrix of confused
contradictory information it was the
election in which the public punished
the Lib Dems for not stopping the Tories
and did so by voting in the Tories
it was the election in which the party
advocating the living wage decisively
lost to a party now advocating the
living wage it was the one in which
Nicola Sturgeon became the most popular
hated politician in Britain and it
reached his climax with the leader of
you Kip resigning and then rapidly
unreasoning in a new form of statecraft
which I can only describe as Bunji
politics this place is a mess we are a
mess we don't know what we want so
trying to be specific and prescriptive
in this unknowable landscape is a fool's
errand it would be a fool indeed who
would try to quantify precisely what say
our broadcasters should do he or she
would be really mad if they tried to
define the purposes and scope of certain
TV channels matter still if they did if
I say some sort of panel of experts and
a mad mad system that would then take
these expert findings and enshrine them
in law oh dear I've called this lecture
we're all in this together and I hope
George Osborne the Prime Minister Regent
doesn't mind doesn't mind my borrowing
his useful phrase for these times now
over the years many political phrases
have caught my eye I remember
particularly in 2010 noticing the old
well e'en contortions language had gone
through to arrive at the Tory campaign
slogan vote for change vote conservative
but believe me saying tonight we're all
in this together I'm not being ironic
playful maybe but deadly serious British
television needs to be at its strongest
with a big global fight ahead
we need to consolidate all our talent
and expertise yet broadcast and
production have drawn evermore discrete
and separate perhaps rather wary of each
other and now politicians have
exacerbated that division ministers have
come to see broadcast those on the
executive branch of television as the
only group to talk to marginalizing the
creative community that drives
production which I believe is actually
the core strength of British television
if we don't do something to redress the
balance to allow the voice of the
creative and production community in TV
to be heard loud and clear the
politicians will become our masters
rather than partners and supporters
acting as if they alone are the experts
it will be a distracting interference
and ultimately harmful to British
television Plus tonight there'll also be
jokes and exactly halfway through the
speech as a form of halftime
entertainment this is absolutely true
and detailed battle secrets
so on we go first off that global fight
I mentioned it really is one centered on
the extraordinary pace of change what
seemed like the white heat of technology
one day can the very next feel as old
and as outdated as the phrase white heat
of technology now no company is too big
to fail
Netscape once looked invincible until it
went the way of CompuServe an event
there are some older members of the
audience here tonight who remember
Microsoft now my first experience of how
quickly the generations adapt their
viewing habits was 18 years ago when I
took my son who was about three to the
cinema for the first time and we went to
see a long and executable film called
flubber and as we came out I asked him
what he thought and he said it was good
it was like a big video you can only see
once and from that from that focused
group of one I determined two things
firstly children are acutely aware of
the limitations of their viewing
environment but secondly it doesn't seem
to spoil their enjoyment of what they're
watching as long as the content is good
they'll put up with much this is good
news for those of us who make quality
programs people will hunt them out by
any means possible and on whichever
device is available hence Amazon and
Netflix are though YouTube pouring money
into generating new content that's the
good news for the creative industry
everyone wants to make television the
bad news is everyone wants to make
television cheaper user-friendly
technology means we're living in both
the golden age of TV and a global bucket
of swill for every Sherlock and Breaking
Bad there's a billion more people
filming their brother squirt baked beans
from his nose and anus so in this
cacophony it's more important than ever
that we have strong popular channels
highly respected for their quality that
act as beacons drawing audiences to the
best content available and providing a
confident home for the best programme
makers faced with the global audience
now British television needs its
champion supporters it needs its
cheerleaders who will they be the
government not while they consistently
talk of reining in our greatest network
the broadcaster's not while most of
their energies are dissipated fighting
off political attacks on their
impartiality or finances now of course
our friends in Whitehall would argue
that as the BBC's Charter comes up for
renewal it's important to see how the
corporation can operate even more
effectively I'd argue back that starting
a debate on how the BBC should be funded
just days after whopping 20% off its
budget without discussion seems pretty
much to me like shutting the stable door
after the horse has been bought gun
but nevermind let's assume the horse is
still alive and revival is a real
possibility even though for obvious
reasons Rolf's Animal Hospital has been
incinerated so I'm going to do some
cheerleading of my own I'm not an expert
I don't run a network I've never
consciously multiplatform I've worked
with channel 4 Sky Atlantic and HBO but
I started with a BBC I've always had a
relationship with it and I feel I owe it
my professional life now that life
really began as a listener hooked on
brilliant comedy shows on Radio 4 like
Hitchhiker's Guide to the galaxy and
Saturday night fried Stephen Fry
tremendously idiosyncratic comedies that
I thought were magical I knew then that
making shows like that was the only
thing I wanted to do I actually started
my professional career as the world's
uncoolest music presenter on Radio
Scotland but given generous
encouragement soon became a comedy
producer for BBC radio at Broadcasting
House the very epicenter of the radio
shows that had inspired me so imagine
how I felt when my first letter from a
listener arrived it was a complaint and
it ended with the words and your new
chief what sort of a name is that for
someone who works for the so called
British Broadcasting Corporation I
pinned it to the front door of my office
bloodied I was quickly on the first rung
of the ladder of BBC management becoming
the early departments script editor I
lasted two months not because of a
scandal but because I couldn't take
myself seriously in a tie eventually and
this is absolutely true when the then
Bishop of Oxford objected to a midnight
joke about the crucifixion on Radio 1
and I was told to apologise I felt it
was time to move on
not for me managing the bbc's torturous
relationship with the establishment
I decided life was too short to deal
with bishop pricks
I'll say that Saku for some water
management I was expecting champagne
Dennis Potter champagne management
wasn't my style and but neither was
business when I went freelance the one
thing I knew I didn't want to do was set
up my own company I wanted to make
comedy not make people redundant because
we weren't making enough comedy
occasionally as I watched friends and
colleagues become channel controllers
and multimillionaires I asked myself if
I did the right thing but I always
answer yes in that time I've seen
channel controllers go
fortunes lost budget slashed and
producers punched I've also watched TV
executives before I marry kaleidoscope
in front of me as they've risen to the
top of one thing and then another
there's about 20 of them whose names
I've grown used to hearing over the
years who might never actually
encountered but whom I assume are very
very good given the only need a couple
of years to do their job before moving
on to the next one they must be they
must be essential components of the TV
industry after all each new initiative
each new reform or inquiry into home
British television conducts itself
throws up one of these individuals onto
its committee as regularly as the dawn
now actually I'm being unfair unfair to
the executives who we in the creative
sector see too often as the enemy and
not as partners in the business of
getting our shows made I'm also being
unfair on myself I am an expert I'm an
expert in what I do as is anyone good at
lighting design producing first ad
script editing presenting directing
ports producing any of the 101
professions that appear on the cast and
crew list at the start of each
production our program making skills are
not just a vague part of our heritage
they are the primary economic component
of our success when they can meet when
the media communications and information
industries make up nearly eight percent
of our GDP larger than the car and oil
and gas
he's put together we need to be heard as
those industries are heard when so many
other countries come here to work with
our crews when so many of our actors are
pinched for projects overseas we need to
be heard
when internationally are writing and
acting and directing and special effects
are being recognized when our formats
and ideas are being sold and reworked
worldwide as never before when as
culture minister advisee
recently pointed out Britain is ranked
the number one soft power in the world
measured for its global influence
through its culture media and education
when our creative community is really
being heard abroad surely we need to be
heard at home but when I see the panel
of experts who've been asked by the
culture secretary to take a root and
branch look at the BBC I don't see
anyone who's a part of that cast and
crew list I see executives media orders
industry gurus all talented people but
are a single person who's made a classic
and enduring television show not a
presenter a writer director or creative
producer no Moffat or Wainwright or
Melville or mercurial nor do I see
anyone from our world-class
post-production industry or from design
or drama no one from the enormous
world-beating service of day-to-day
production to give their views to
offload their expertise on the
difficulties and the joys and the
challenges of making world standard
public service broadcasting
oh and no viewers - just people from the
executive branch of television it's like
a car company was looking into what cars
should make next but only spoke to the
managers and not to any of the engineers
or drivers you cannot have a meaningful
root and branch review of television if
you're only going to deal with one
branch now I wonder if this why do
politicians not talk to us creatives is
it because we don't wear a time are they
more wary of us because we deal with
intangible stuff made-up stories on
quantum
viable and unpredictable entertainments
that make us interesting but not really
serious the sort of person is good to be
photographed chatting to at a thank you
reception for the Arts rather than
properly engaging without a boardroom
meeting
deciding how a crucial segments of the
arts should be run maybe that's why
executives who have staff and offices
and budgets and ties get invited on to
committees every year while creatives
are brought along for canapes every five
talk to us no one comes into contact
will regularly with the hard economics
of making a budget work than a
production team every time I make a show
I am a small businessman responsible for
hundreds of employees in charge of a
budget of millions of pounds and of
course if the project isn't successful
the work would come back in America the
key production personnel the writers the
first ad senior researchers are credited
as producers they are rewarded for their
key creative input on my HBO show veep
which we shot in Baltimore we had a set
visit from the state governor who came
to thank us for the work we were
bringing to Maryland a true essential
role in the business of making good
television was acknowledged and I
mentioned earlier viewers if Britain is
at the top of its game in TV creativity
I think it's because we have the best
audience in the world I think the
British public yearns for good stories
stimulating argument and original ideas
it knows [ __ ] when it sees it soon
tires of the same-old same-old and
hungers for something new all the time
it makes the difficult and takes it
takes the difficult the idiosyncratic
and it makes it popular that's why we in
television should feel lucky to be born
in this country or to have come here to
work I love it that we think nothing of
the fact that are sure about baking
is a key part of our primetime viewing
or shows about antiques or family trees
or polar bears we don't appreciate how
deeply weird it is not to be fed one cop
show after another that's what I
remember from watching television when I
was growing up in the 70s and 80s the
range in front of me I could watch smart
comedy like Monty Python and not the 9
o'clock news but I also had Bruce and
his generation game Walker and wise and
no one to tell me only one type of show
was for me and not the other
I loved it that I could glide from
Fawlty Towers to a horizon documentary
on voyagers tricked pass Saturn for a
comedy and a space geek that was
satisfying even if it seems a little
embarrassingly sad talking about it now
but what I take from then is that
British television said this that
everything the whole world of knowledge
and all creativity is on offer is for
you all of you no matter what your
background you are all equally welcomed
to the most varied content the world's
best program makers could deliver but
yes there were limits on the number of
channels and and hours we didn't fill a
limit on ideas and ambition and that
pride in what we made has stayed with me
all I can do if I want to be any part of
that tradition and make sure is make
sure that I make the best shows I
possibly can and treat my audience with
respect and intelligence so recently
it's been the biggest source of pride to
me that veep assure me primarily for an
American audience that this show was
very much a British production it was
written in the UK it was edited here
scored here was produced here using
British directors our editors were
awarded by their American peers with the
ACE award for best edited half-hour of
US television our writers when the
Guild of America Award we've received
Emmy nominations across all departments
now this comes as no surprise to me
there's no magic secret and it's
certainly not my doing
I simply trust British talent as I've
been trusted I believe we are the best
in the world that what we do and I'm
prepared to act on that basis now
actually my biggest surprise about
working for HBO was it it seemed very
familiar it's quite a small tight unit
where I only had to deal with one
sometimes two executives they placed the
creative voice front and center of what
they did notes were intelligent and
offered as suggestions only if very
rarely I said no I don't feel that will
work they came back with good grace and
said literally Amanda it's your show you
decide what's best this is the secret
formula but here's the thing that's
exactly how the BBC worked some 15 years
ago the best US shows are modeling
themselves of what used to make British
television so world-beating
to have a broadcast to have faith in you
and leave you to get on with it was the
very essence of British television not
just under the public service remit but
in the commercial field as well
itv and then channel 4 and now sky are
channels that have hoovered up not just
the BBC's executives to run their own
channels but it's template quality
because quality brings audiences look
where that faith brings rewards now all
across our domestic output from BBC one
to Sky Atlantic Happy Valley the Tunnel
broadchurch the fall line of duty shows
that place trust in the creative process
and in the viewer UK television is
copying the u.s. formula that was copied
from UK television
u.s. prime time schedules are no
littered with those quirky formats from
the UK the who do you think you are and
the variants on Strictly Come Dancing as
well as the single camera non audience
sitcom which we brought into the
mainstream first we have changed
international viewing for the better and
I think sometimes our political partners
forget this here's one instance George
Osborne recently said in an interview
that there should be more TV dramas that
have extended runs so we're not left
behind in the increasing habit of people
watching us box sets I agree but what he
fails to realize is that the best of
those u.s. dramas have been have been
the ones that have taken a leaf out of
the British playbook limiting their runs
to 13 episodes instead of 22 with shows
like Game of Thrones and true detective
on 10
it's the refusal to dilute quality for
quantity that has made these series so
good and by the way not so long that
viewing them in one binge is totally
unrealistic so no let's be more
assertive the international market
flatters us with imitation now is the
time to strike out not huddled down if
the license fee is under strain then
let's supplement it not carve it up
thank pushing ourselves more
commercially abroad use the BBC's named
one of the most recognized brands in the
world and use the reputation of British
television across all networks to
capitalize financially overseas be more
aggressive in selling our shows through
advertising through proper international
subscription channels free up BBC
Worldwide to be fully commercial
whatever it takes frankly let's not be
icky and modest about making money
let's monetize the bejesus Marion Joseph
out of our programmes
abroad so that money can come back take
some pressure off the license fee at
home and be invested in even more
ambitious quality shows the curly add to
our value protect protect public service
broadcasting at home by displaying the
arrogance of our convictions abroad
instead what do we get Don an eerie
silence settles on central London then
bang tanks and troops move into
Broadcasting House their instructions
close down the BBC a cyberattack
obliterates its websites while all local
radio stations and DJ's are evacuated
and pulped in London the army handcuffs
Lord Hall and escorts him off to a
museum by noon live atrocities can be
seen taking place behind Fiona Bruce
Salford takes a little longer to
subjugate us for army squadrons land in
Manchester and then have to take a
shuttle bus in Glasgow in Glasgow NIC
Robertson is tied up and fired by cannon
into BBC Scotland it only takes a few
minutes to tweet his whereabouts throw
open the doors and let locals do their
worst meanwhile in London ruthlessly
remorselessly a lone masked figure moves
through the BBC's confusing corridors
killing off the presenters one by one
Dimbleby is done
Norton eviscerated maryberry is cut
through like one of her delicious
sponges
meanwhile Simon Schama is history all
that's left to defend the battered
corporation is one man Professor Brian
Cox the masked destroyer goes for him
and it's quickly apparent that Brian Cox
may be clever and good-looking but as
we've long suspected his rubbish in
hand-to-hand combat cops flees to the
canteen area hoping to barricade himself
in it's no use the automatically opening
safety doors are no obstacle to the
hooded assassin who steps through and
destroys Cox with a single punch to his
beautiful clever face with him all hope
of the BBC remaining in its present form
the assailant stands in the canteen and
removes his mask there revealed is
Jeremy Clarkson laughing at the irony of
destroying the BBC in a room full of
readily available hot meals
I exaggerate of course for comic effect
but if you're all laughing at this
entirely fictitious conspiracy theory
then you must recognize something that
rings true because we do do we not feel
under attack foreign owners are now
buying into our networks when we should
be beating the world with our shows so
where are our cheerleaders if public
service broadcasting one of the best
things we've ever done creatively as a
country if it was a car industry our
ministers would be out championing it
overseas trying to win contracts
boasting of the British jobs that would
bring if the BBC were a weapon system
half the cabinet would be on a plane to
Saudi Arabia to tell them how brilliant
it was and yet it's quite the reverse
they talk of cutting down to size of
reining in imperialist ambitions hiding
off of limiting the scope and they do it
with automatically of a doctor ever so
reasonably urging his patient to
consider the benefits of assisted
suicide
at its mildest this talk is a background
hum in the form of government ministers
telling us what shows these think we
should be making as if there were
televisions chief commissioners of
programs for example the culture sector
II John Whittingdale recently said in an
interview that quote arguably I'd keep
David Attenborough and I'm not sure how
practical doubtless which is given the
natural life cycle of the human
presenter unless we're prepared to
preserve him like the Russians do Lenin
but then there was ministerial confusion
on the subject of Strictly Come Dancing
as one called it fantastic on the fifth
of July only to clash with Whittingdale
who called the show debatable on the
14th of July but who then no doubt under
pressure from his Chancellor swiveled
calling it admirable by the 19th and
then shuffled back ever so slightly to
absolutely appropriate this lunchtime it
was such an elegantly perform maneuvers
really should go on the show the point
is even in just one program it's very
difficult to get a clear idea of what
they're really thinking it's just like
dealing with actual TV commissioners
but but Commissioners in direct control
of the Treasury so what worries me is
that a politician's Doh intend to act on
their extremely subjective opinions and
be their increasingly falling into the
trap of thinking that because they've
won a parliamentary majority they know
how a majority of the public thinks it's
a dangerous path in itself a creeping
Imperial ambition that does
international harm to our stock variety
and Hollywood Reporter no daily feature
stories about our television service
powering down BBC for becoming a shadow
of what it was BBC three destined for
online proud boasts about redundancies
acceptance of cuts channel for toyed
with over privatisation doubts or it not
fully answered at lunchtime today to
court a question I've been repeatedly
asked by the US TV industry what the
hell are you guys thinking today that
looks like we're going mad this is
toxifying something that could otherwise
make more money internationally simply
put it's bad capitalism as I said at the
start of this talk I collect political
phrases and the one I return to again
and again is a sentence from Tony Blair
in 2004 one year on from the invasion of
Iraq and in defense of his decision to
invade he said do I know I'm right
judgments aren't the same as facts
instinct is not a science I only know
what I believe now that concluding
phrase I only know what I believe is a
stunning reversal of about two and a
half thousand years of rational inquiry
because normally normally we believe
what we know normally we seek evidence
and form conclusions on the basis of
what we find
instead Blair turns belief self-belief
at that into an absolute effect and
knowledge into something a lot more
qualified and imperfect so we have to
ask of any political decision is it
being made unto thee I only know what I
believe doctrine is it being made
because the hunch the gut feeling is
considered more definitive than the
evidence obtained that the political
opinion is more valid will become truth
and has already become law prior to
actual investigation and proper inquiry
so today does it explain the one-sided
nature of the appointments to the panel
of experts looking at the BBC or the
extremely manufactured set of question
marks against public sector broadcasting
I say manufacture because I really can't
hear from the general public a grown
swell of opposition to the BBC's
outrageous Saturday night scheduling
there are no online petitions to shut
down the BBC's online cake recipes of
public demos to close it's apparently
left-wing news a new service by the way
that has higher levels of trust in it
than in any newspaper we seem to be in
some artificially concocted zone of
outrage that emerged fully formed around
the time of the election a strangely
choreographed set of editorials and
columns and private briefings these
opinions have taken on a momentum of
their own that they acquire mass the
appear almost like solid fact or at
least enough like it that even our dear
BBC news service is obliged to report
them taking us to the exquisite irony
that we start to believe the BBC is not
to be trusted because we heard it on the
BBC
where does it come from this spooky
force bending the ear of Chancellor's
and ministers and civil servants and
asking them to call the BBC let's for
the sake of argument call this force m4
mysterious
what does em say em says the BBC is
doing too much across too many media
outlets
it's a broadcaster so shouldn't have a
web presence sub-dominant it crowds out
the competition
and yet look at the times we live in
what will once separate forms of
communication or separate media are now
increasingly interconnected and
exchangeable so we no longer have a TV
market a newspaper market a publishing
market we have indisputably an old media
market I didn't write those last few
sentences
James word update in his 2009 McTaggart
lecture we no longer have a TV market a
newspaper market a publishing market we
have indisputably an all media market
this is so true newspapers now poured
and vodcast radio goes interactive even
cinemas and theaters
Beamen live networked events for any
cultural or news organization to survive
it has to adapt across all platforms so
why does em criticize the BBC for
wanting to do so and for doing it well
it only make sense of the BBC's web
presence was pointless and amateurish
but in fact this thing is in the top 100
websites in the world currently around
60th I think and the only British old
one on that list
it makes no economic or cultural sense
to tell this country's best online media
presence one that serves the public
freely that projects our cultural impact
globally to make itself a little bit
worse
we deserve we deserve to be at the top
table but instead we're being told to
break our table up for firewood
capitalism is pursued where it helps the
bbc's competitors and I'm always
peculiar form of Maoist state control is
advocated when it doesn't Facebook and
Google came along and it ate up all of
newspapers classified ads yeah it's the
BBC who are no ads that gets the blame
well as for Google and Facebook to get
the helpful tax arrangements from HMRC
will the root and branch investigating
be looking at this rather twisted
looking route but n this mysterious
force arguing for change won't stop
there the cognitive dissonance it omits
now hits program making with it says a
perfectly reasonable proposition don't
spend licence money pursuing ratings
grabbing projects that the commercial
sector could just as easily do can you
instead be a little less populist
but how do you predict the popularity of
a program maybe a panel of Whitehall
experts will be set up to hear each
program idea in advance and determine
whether it sounds like it'll be a hit or
dot like some perverse imitation of the
successful talent shows that that same
panel its current being asked to
restrict though if the Ministry of
Culture were to find a way to predict
the future
I'd suggest it doesn't spend all its
time on TV shows no programs like the
Great British Bake Off and who do you
think you are
strike me as shows that started off
niche and became popular Gavin & Stacey
started on BBC three the office was on
rather obscurely scheduled slot late on
BBC to the thick of it was on BBC four
to begin with in fact is no one knew
these shows were going to be so popular
they were allowed to grow in the public
consciousness get nudged into the
mainstream in a way we simply couldn't
do now if the BBC was creatively
stricted as is being suggested popular
unleash our points on a continuous and
evolving spectrum to cut this valuable
resource up is to damage all parts of it
how is that productive but M for
mysterious is nothing if not resilient
it focuses its dissonant noise ever more
tightly in turn umming wail targeted at
human thought itself for it asks is it
not reasonable that we look to see if
the BBC is too left-wing the culture
secretary today says it's not coming
from him but why does this question hang
so heavy in the ether like a thick
Edinburgh ha full disclosure I product
of the BBC stand before you as a
guardian reader I also do so as a
telegraph reader one of my first Jobs
was producing the news quiz on Radio 4
and scanning every newspaper every day
for weeks on end made me instantly aware
that no one newspaper told the whole
story
the closer I peered at the page the more
holes I look through so it's become a
habit to get the Guardian and telegraph
every day to get something approximating
to both sides of the story and our
favourite game each morning over
breakfast is to compare the photos on
the two front pages The Guardian
frequently has something uncompromising
a picture of sludge or an abattoir
well well the Telegraph goes out of its
way to feature a photo of a smiling
blonde woman in her 20s even if it's
under the headline the sister of the man
who died so you soon you soon get to
recognize their tics now the BBC is not
allowed to have tics it has to remain
impartial but impossi ality shouldn't
mean dull it has to it has to feel
fearless questioning pushing against the
establishment view from whatever party
that's why Nick Robertson Jeremy Paxman
Andrew Neil are so good at what they do
but hang on Nick was once chairman of
the Young Conservatives Paxman has since
outed himself as a one nation Tory an
Andrew Neil has had a very close
association with Rupert Murdoch after
that former chairman like Lords grade
and pattern to conservative peers and
you have a very convincing case if you
want one that there's a pretty clear
very deliberate right-wing bias in the
BBC except I don't see it that way
because Robertson Paxman and Neil are
professionals they hold to the highest
professional standards for my money
Andrew Neil gets more surprising
admissions and squirming revelations out
of politicians on a daily basis than
anyone on television and long may he do
so so the question shouldn't be do these
people have a political past but what do
they do with a knowledge and experience
and passion for politics anyone with a
passion and understanding of the subject
is bound to have engaged with it the
alternative is to have a parade of
political eunuchs on a screen just
reading out what's put in front of them
with no personal connection to the
subject you might as well have Seri read
the news and just as when I see Michael
Portillo present great train journeys of
the world I don't look out for him
making subtle suggestions that the
journey would be a lot better if the
line were privatized
so - should we stop assuming that any
presenter who has historically come from
the political left would be equally
biased to view those who privately have
left wing views as more prone to bias
than those who privately hold right-wing
ones is itself a bias and an insult to
the professionalism of all we see bias
and imbalance from our own prejudice so
we could have fun charting an
exaggerated right-wing history of the
BBC as easily as a left-wing one for
every boys from the black stuff there
was a Dallas glorifying capitalism at
ripping of the color and songs of praise
reasserting the permanence of old
establishment ideals and bishoprics for
every for every drama about homelessness
there's Antiques Roadshow weekly and
literally enforcing the Thatcherite
principle or selling off the family
silver for every left-wing comic there's
an army of business and economic experts
reinforcing the views of the banking
community and the market has accepted
fact and by God how could a corporation
be left-wing when it has perpetuated the
career of Ann Widdecombe the wisest
words I've read and all this come from
Toby Young who wrote recently in The
Spectator prior to appearing on question
time what I've often heard conservatives
complain that the BBC packs the audience
with lefties not true the makers of the
program
bend over backwards to try to ensure
that the audience contain a broad
cross-section of political views by
definition a majority of them won't be
conservative voters but that's the
country's anti Tory bias not the BBC's
and of course that is the point the BBC
is funded by and speaks to the country
the country is not the government more
people paid for the BBC and watch it
then vote for any one political party
and politicians convinced that because
they are in government their views and
values are the majority opinion of the
day are slaves to an illusion
I'm sorry to go on about this but I
think this takes us to the fundamental
problem the problem of I only know what
I believe which is now putting pressure
on public service broadcasting to
conform to the political norms of the
party in power no matter how slim its
majority a whole oh it's share of the
vote the government has recently warned
the BBC to be balanced in its coverage
of the EU referendum why if there's a
clear cause for this warning the
government should point it out if there
isn't why the need for a warning and how
now our BBC reporters to proceed
subconsciously code into a fear that any
two probing and analysis of a sensitive
point say the economic advantages or
disadvantages of immigration might lead
to censure or reprimand the BBC is a
mirror into which Britain gazes every
day it reflects the country sometimes
flatteringly but also truthfully they
must surely keep asking questions about
that country digging around startling
annoying there is a disruptive element
to creativity as well as an affirmative
one not necessarily political but born
from a keen sense of duty to make
society and community stronger through
analyzing it and probing outside its
comfort zone
meantime politicians should say openly
what they believe if they distrust the
BBC they should say it they just don't
like it they should say it not
commissioned charts and experts to
arrive at that conclusion for them Phil
itting information and statistics down
to look like incontrovertible fact to
take one example page 24 of the
government's Charter Review document
it's taken up with a massive chart
showing how the BBC has expanded from
two
in 1984 to nine in 2014 I think it's
meant to look chilly what the graph
doesn't show is how much every other
broadcaster has expanded in that time
nor does it mention that in 1984 there
were 61 channels available in the UK and
that this has expanded by 2014 to 536 so
you could say if you like the BBC has
gone from having 3.2 percent of the
channels in 1994 down to 1.6 percent of
them today conclusion if you like to get
the best value for the license PA the
BBC ought to have more channels now I
could stand here and keep patting back
government statistics until the Chilkoot
report comes home I could point out how
they continually paint the BBC as a
bloated monster but don't sure how it's
dwarfed by its commercial rivals they
spend more on the rights to Premiership
football alone than the corporation
spends on all its content but really
what's the point numbers will be
pummeled into whatever conclusion needs
reaching many of the arguments from the
experts in Whitehall turn out to be
fictions as imaginative as the ones we
in the TV industry get prizes for or as
false as the people in leaflets issued
by the Department of Work and Pensions
so let's stop playing games let's talk
properly and honestly about what we
value and want to preserve in the BBC in
the end it comes down to our personal
experience of the cooperation as viewers
and listeners so here's one of mine I
mentioned at the start I was a bit of an
astronomy geek so of course I was
disturbingly excited when the New
Horizons satellite shot past pootle a
few weeks back discovery did a very good
documentary days later fast-paced high
tech lots of graphics and photos
entertaining I just felt I was missing
something perhaps a little bit more
uninterrupted time with the science so
happily there was the one hour sky at
night special
the next night this show was passionate
but patient the emotional pool came
through watching the two scientist
presenters Chris Linn taught and Maggie
Adair and Porco be present at the New
Horizons headquarters in Maryland and
react in real-time to the data as it
came through we watched their enthusiasm
and their relief and their puzzlement at
some of the photographs but because of
their expertise they were able to talk
us through why it was so surprising not
to see any impact craters on flittle
perp little why everyone was so amazed
at the shots of mountain ranges bigger
than Everest made of compacted water ice
that told us this world we'd all written
off as a cold dead rock at the edge of
the solar system was a living active
environment overturning the views of all
the experts the program was unrushed
intelligent and ambitious and I thought
of how it connected to the wonderful
stargazing live on BBC 2 where the
schedules unhampered by commercials are
cleared yearly for three live 90-minute
programs on space and astronomy of how
the expertise of the sky at night team
is turned on a mainstream audience
brought there through stargazing lives
on presenters Brian Cox and Dara Abram
of how Cox the brain have had careers
and audiences nurtured on the BBC
through successful documentaries like
wonders of the solar system and seasoned
comedy they mark the week of how these
different audiences are then plugged in
to an ambitious format that relies on
the BBC's scale and expertise in live
outside broadcasts from around the
country and so it ripples out to the
work and the independent sector all
these and similar shows bring to the
training it gives
searchers and producers who go on to
work for other networks and most
importantly in this instance to the
schools with these shows and online
projects such as the BBC's year of
science have led to a huge jump in those
choosing science GCSE and a-level that
for me is what the BBC is there for
connecting connecting highbrow and
mainstream knowledge and entertainment
getting you with the world and this
whole country to its culture for all its
faults for all its faults it's a pretty
good alignment of the planets tampering
with it is madness the question
shouldn't be how do we cut it down to
size but why should we in future the
ascendant nations
the highest living standards will be
those who master not land and material
but ideas and technologies not my words
but the words of Rupert Murdoch in his
1989 McTaggart nature
we should heat them now the British are
very good at calling out nonsense so if
the British public feel they're being
[ __ ] of that if they get the
slightest whiff what's been done to the
BBC is purely political then I urge the
relevant ministers to leave the country
get out now
for they really don't know what's about
to hit their fan the anger won't be
divided on party lines at once it will
swell Beyond Guardian readers and
Telegraph readers - all in between and
beyond her regard the BBC is one of the
best features fixtures of British daily
life so politicians say what you mean
broadcasters argue back don't adopt a
position of automatic compromise then
maybe in effect concedes everything and
to those in production we are the public
duty to defend whether by continuing to
come up with challenging provocative
shows disruptive and eccentric sort the
world expects from us or by reporting
flaws in political logic forensically
analyzing any weakness in argument or by
going out there into the wider world and
winning the praise and the prizes we
deserve to make the point that a
significant British industry of god of
global standing is being harmed by
woolly thinking thinking that simply
isn't good enough and it doesn't meet
the quality standards the country
expects from this industry ladies and
gentlemen it's been a tremendous honor
to be invited to speak to the UK TV
industry but it's an even greater honor
to work in it let's all defend it thank
you very much